madame la Première ministre vous occupez
votre poste depuis un an sans que
personne ici ne vous ai accordé son vote
de confiance depuis un an de 49,3 en
49,3 vous assurez le service après-vente
des caprices du président de la
République en l'espace d'un an vous avez
fait de notre pays une poudrière bravo
Madame la première ministre quel
anniversaire aujourd'hui encore le
président de la République vit dans une
réalité parallèle à présent Emmanuel
Macron est le seul qui croit encore en
Emmanuel Macron vous êtes les seuls dans
le pays qui croit pouvoir tourner la
page nouveau répondons jamais jamais
nous n'accepterons de vous voyez deux
ans de vie aux Français 34000 euros de
retraite à chacun d'eux et que vous les
brutalisiez au propre comme au figuré le
pays tout entier opposé à votre réforme
les syndicats comme le Parlement bravo
Madame la première ministre quel
anniversaire la macronie se vit à
présent comme une citadelle a siéger
alors vous dis à bientôt lisez
l'alternative politique que nous sommes
en même temps que vous banalisez
l'extrême droite madame la Première
ministre vous dites que nous ferions de
l'anti parlementarisme l'anti
parlementarisme c'est vous 11 49.3 votre
actif et des manœuvres pour empêcher le
vote de l'abrogation de la réforme les
extrémistes c'est vous vous avez refusé
toutes les sorties par le haut que nous
avions proposé référendum ou retour
devant le peuple jamais un gouvernement
n'avait eu aussi peur du peuple il vous
reste à comprendre qu'en démocratie il
est seul souverain
madame la Première ministre quand
comprendrez-vous que la représentation
nationale n'est mise en paillasson ni
une chambre d'enregistrement des lubies
du président madame la Première ministre
joyeux anniversaire surtout n'hésitez
pas à partir vous la Cinquième
République et votre réforme des
retraites
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la Présidente panot alors
on l'a bien compris vous êtes
définitivement fâché avec nos
institutions parce que le programme que
nous mettons en œuvre madame la
Présidente panneau c'est celui sur
lequel le président de la République a
été élu et définitivement vous ne la ne
mettez pas mais ce n'est pas le Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais Emmanuel Macron que les
Français ont choisi et je vous le
confirme nous continuerons à mettre en
œuvre le programme pour lequel le
président de la République a été élu et
vous de votre côté madame la Présidente
panneau c'est grave ce que vous faites
vous montez aux Français vous mentez aux
Français
du matin au soir vous mentez aux
Français vous voulez faire croire qu'on
pourrait d'un traître plume rayé 18
milliards d'euros de recettes pour notre
système de retraite alors une fois pour
une fois dites aux Françaises que vous
proposez vous proposez de baisser les
pensions vous proposez d'augmenter les
cotisations et de baisser le pouvoir
d'achat des travailleurs pour une fois
dites la vérité voyez madame panot et
vous et vraiment vous êtes fâchés aussi
avec le fonctionnement de cette
Assemblée nationale vous avez fait de
l'obstruction de l'obstruction à cause
de vous madame la Présidente panneau
malgré 82 80 heures de débat vos
collègues n'ont pas pu examiner au-delà
de l'article 3 de la réforme des
retraites et maintenant après
l'obstruction d'un texte qui a été
approuvé qui a été validé par le Conseil
mais qui a été validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel qu'est-ce que vous
proposez au bout aujourd'hui vous
proposez d'abroger la réforme c'est tout
à fait représentatif de ce que vous êtes
madame la Présidente panneau et de ce
que vous proposez votre groupe des
propositions jamais mais par contre
attisé les colères
empêcher le Parlement de fonctionner
c'est ça votre mode de fonctionnement
pour notre cylindre pour notre plaid ce
que nous voulons c'est proposer des
réponses aux Français et pas plus tard
que tout à l'heure j'engagerai des
concertations avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales pour construire
de nouveaux progrès
[Applaudissements]